y los habitantes de la capital chadiana
abandonan la ciudad muchos están
preocupados por lo que pueda suceder en
el país luego de que el presidente
idriss deby fuera asesinado
inesperadamente lo que esperamos es el
momento de la transición no queremos
otro representante militar en el poder
durante esta transición porque habrá
problemas nuevamente se necesita a un
civil
son muchos en chad los que no quieren al
nuevo consejo militar en el poder sin
embargo los representantes del ejército
aseguraron que no será para siempre
las fuerzas de defensa y de seguridad no
buscan tomar el poder
me gustaría asegurarle a la gente que
los miembros del consejo militar
devolverán el poder a un gobierno civil
a través de elecciones libres y
democráticas en un plazo de 18 meses
el hijo del mandatario fallecido mahamat
idriss deby dirigirá el consejo militar
de transición y no el presidente del
parlamento como dicta la constitución
ante el panorama que se avecina eeuu
anunció que su embajada en chad seguirá
elaborando pero permanece bajo el estado
de salida ordenada por las
preocupaciones de seguridad en el país
huiyuan lo que queremos ver es una
transición que sea consistente con la
constitución de chad las instituciones
de chat están consagradas en su carta
magna pero queremos que los elementos de
esa constitución estén protegidos en el
futuro ya sea que eso implique una
transición del poder mientras los países
de occidente perdieron a un importante
aliado en la lucha contra el yihadismo
al norte de áfrica las autoridades
chadianas decretaron un toque de queda
nocturno y el cierre de todas las
fronteras